my wildest swing for the fences Theory
here is that this Super Mario movie is
gonna be a musical Peach is peaches
peaches peaches nailed it
fun fact that song Peaches yeah that
thing is now eligible for the best
original song Oscar Academy
award-winning songwriter King Koopa he
has a nice ring to it doesn't it hello
Internet it's a me a film Theory the
show that definitely beat the obstacle
course on the first try so the Super
Mario Brothers movie came out let me
just say it it was a blast was it high
Cinema Kino as the kids online say no
obviously not the pacing was a bit
uneven the random 80s pop song inserts
just didn't work and Peach's motivations
for taking Mario with her on the
adventure were weaker than a stack of
goombas but darn it if I didn't have a
smile plastered across my face the
second the GameCube jingle played as a
cell phone ringtone or when the brothers
platform their way through a 2d
construction site or when the DK rap
kicked into high gear during Donkey
Kong's WrestleMania entrance so awesome
on that topic though that was probably
my biggest complaint about the movie the
creator of the DK rap isn't credited
yeah well all the other songs have their
writers and musicians properly credited
the DK rap is just from Donkey Kong 64.
real classy there Universal I mean I
know Seth Rogen said objectively one of
the worst rap songs of all time but that
doesn't mean that the man behind this
masterpiece epic game composer Grant
Perko should be overlooked artists
deserve to be credited for their hard
work and that includes the DK rap no
matter what Seth Rogen thinks about it
and the snub was obviously enough to
upset Grant so here's what I propose
loyal theorists let's work together to
change the Mario movie if you have
yourself a Twitter account go and use
that toxic platform to do some good
today tweet at Universal or specifically
at universalpix pics asking them to
change the credits in the digital
release of the Mario movie to include
all the proper credits for the writers
and performers of the DK rap and make
sure you use the hashtag
savethedkrap so we can get this puppy
trending if it gets enough attention if
media outlets and YouTubers and
streamers start making enough noise with
the story maybe Grant and everyone else
who worked on this thing will get the
credit that they deserve for writing a
song that so many people love or at
least me it was I was so hyped when they
played this I will fully admit my bias
here I'm not usually the type to get
really excited about nostalgic like
member Berry stuff but man that was an
Easter egg I did not see coming and it
hit hard but beyond the music the
missing credits and the Beautiful
animations we all know what I was really
there to see the lore let me tell you
their friends there was so much in this
thing we here at theist HQ actually have
a ton of ideas and we're definitely
going to be diving further once it's
available to scour frame by frame so
super jump on that subscribe button
right now so you get notified of when
all those episodes come out but as of
today in true video game fashion we're
gonna be speedrunning our way through
four mini theories that may just change
the way you look at these core Mario
characters forever today we're covering
everything from Peach's mysterious
Origins and the Twisted logic of the
Mushroom Kingdom to the realities of The
Wider meta Mario verse so suck down a
mushroom and design yourself a cart
friendos let's go so let's kick things
off with Theory number one you cannot
die in the Mushroom Kingdom one subtle
detail that I think most people
overlooked in this new movie is how they
visualize the damage that Mario was
taking through all of the punishment
that he takes in the Mushroom Kingdom
Mario comes away basically unscathed for
instance in the arena battle against
Donkey Kong Mario gets rocked he's
grabbed smashed tossed slammed and made
into the equivalent of plumber Plato and
yet his body reflects none of that
damage he is literally on the verge of
passing out there's not a scraper bruise
on him either during or after the fight
big deal right Mario movie what do I
expect it's not like they're going to
show the main character bleeding or
something except that's exactly what
they show us during the movie's final
fight during the final battle all the
characters are sucked back out of the
warpipe and launched into Brooklyn and
here we once again see Mario taking a
lot of Hard Knocks except this time his
body is showing all the damage complete
with the black eye and a bruise on his
cheek I mean these sorts of design
choices aren't made casually especially
for big feature film collaborations
between two companies like this and
especially when one of those companies
is Nintendo one that so protective of
their characters that they gave Disney
notes about how Bowser would hold his
teacup in Wreck-It Ralph it's also not
like Bowser was rougher with Mario out
here than anything we saw happen inside
the Mushroom Kingdom there are multiple
occasions where both Mario and Luigi
probably should have died during their
Adventures adding to this idea early on
in the movie we see Bowser uses flame
breath on a disobedient Koopa but
instead of killing him this act scorches
off all his outer flesh transforming
that Koopa from a turtle into a dry
bones what this tells us is that
people's biology seem to act differently
across the different worlds or kingdoms
of the Mario universe and that for
whatever reason the Mushroom Kingdom is
one where your spirit or living self is
somehow contained within the bones of
your body what this tells me is that in
the Final Act of the movie as Luigi is
lowered down into the pitilava and
nearly Burns to death what really would
have happened if that scene had
continued would have been him turning
into a living skeleton rather than
immediate and permanent death still a
downgrade from fleshy human status for
sure but hey at least it's not death
death so take a chill pill there Luigi
Death only appears to be permanent if
it's out in the real world theory number
two did you notice the Cavalcade of
Nintendo references that are packed into
this movie of course you did it's
impossible not to notice them there were
so many in this thing that the new
Rockstar's Easter egg video that breaks
this puppy down is gonna be longer than
the actual movie some of my personal
favorites obviously the songs I
mentioned earlier like the DK rap but
there was also the Super Mario wrap from
their old TV show that was used in the
commercial oh where the Mario brothers
and plumens all the construction signs
have demon watch characters on them
that's really fun there's the shot of
Mario vs Bowser frame like it's a KO in
Super Smash at the end and that moment
that Mario defeats Bowser by launching
him with his tail a direct callback to
Mario 64. but it was the non-mario game
references that got me the most
interested Mario has a Toy R Wing model
from Star Fox in his room there's an
f-zero poster hanging from his wall to
punch out Pizzeria is a big old nod to
the boxing Adventures of Little Mac
which is also fitting since Mario was
the referee of that original game
there's also an ice climber's Easter egg
on one of the awnings of the streets of
Brooklyn is the whole scene of him
playing Kid Icarus which we're going to
talk about a lot more later but to me
it's what isn't there that stands out
the most in a movie that's literally a
Nintendo Victory lap crammed full of
every IP they got the omissions are
telling did you notice the distinct lack
of anything related to Zelda Metroid
Pokemon Kirby well that tells me that
Nintendo has carved those IP out to shop
around I suspect that according to the
contract anything that appears in this
movie would have to have been committed
to a production in partnership with
illumination and since those are the
main IP that Nintendo is lining up to
continue their multimedia movie Push
keeping them out was an intentional
choice to have him remain as free agents
speaking of missing characters the Mario
movie is literally a timeline of Mario
games the whole thing begins with Mario
and Luigi talking to form and Spike
about their construction jobs and being
part of the wrecking crew and it all
ends with Bowser's wedding where he
wears the exact outfit from Mario
Odyssey basically this thing is giving
you a complete picture of Mario across
the years beginning to end and then they
put in practically every power-up you'd
want to see in this thing mushrooms
Stars fireflowers sure that's to be
expected but also mini mushrooms Tanuki
suits ice flowers the freaking cat suit
that made me wonder where could they
possibly go next when your first film is
literally a highlight reel of 35 years
worth of games what else can you
possibly include well obviously with
Bowser temporarily out of commission the
next one has gotta star Wario and our
meme Lord and Savior Waluigi trying to
nap Yoshi eggs from Yoshi's Island that
one seems like a no-brainer maybe you
throw some Koopalings in there for good
measure and after that we're gonna be
taking a trip to space to explore some
galaxies or finally I'd expect we meet
our last and most important character
Rosalina and it's then in the proposed
third movie of this Trilogy where we'll
be revealed peaches Origins which then
brings us to Theory number three Peach
is a star during a scene in Act 2 is
Mario Peach and Toad are on their way to
try and recruit the Kong Army against
Bowser's Invasion to Trio spend a night
in a field full of fire flowers Mario
and Peach use the opportunity to do some
character development telling each other
and the audience about their backstories
and motivations and it's here that peach
reveals that she doesn't know where
she's from the only thing that she does
know is that it's not the Mushroom
Kingdom it's here that we see her
earliest memory arriving in the Mushroom
Kingdom from a pipe as an infant and
then getting adopted by the Toads Mario
wonders if Peach could be a human from
his world but given the way Peach reacts
to this question I kind of doubt it she
just kind of softly Smiles turns away
looks up at the night sky and says it's
a big universe out there with a lot of
galaxies now that right there isn't a
giant neon billboard spelling out Fury
baits I don't know what is so obviously
it seems like they're setting up some
future films to explore Mario Galaxy
stuff and that stuff is going to be
directly related to Peach's backstory
but I suspect we can actually get more
specific here hear me out on this but
what if Peach is literally a humanoid
star one of the superstars that somehow
take in human form might sound like a
stretch but let's look at some of the
evidence if we look back at that scene
where Baby Peach arrives in the Mushroom
Kingdom there's lots of little details
that start adding to the theory firstly
Peach arrives out of a pipe that's
constantly glowing unlike Mario who
arrives in a pipe that flashes as it
spits him out and then turns entirely
dark that right there tells me there's
some really powerful Magic on the other
side of that pipe and the most powerful
thing that we see in this world are the
superstars and wouldn't you know it they
glow just like the pipe secondly the
skirt that Baby Peach is wearing in the
scene is covered in a repeating pattern
of stars and moons a character is
designed in an important flashback like
this likely had input from everyone up
the chain of command in both
illumination and Nintendo so this detail
is something that they 100 wanted in
there thirdly peach is clearly powerful
not only is she a capable Warrior but it
also appears like she's always been
powerful since she was able to do the
obstacle course that Mario struggles
with on her first try the only other
time we see anyone as capable as her is
when Mario and Luigi have the power of
the Superstar at the end of the movie
also this is a bit of a minor point but
I figured I should mention it we also
see both Baby Mario and Baby Luigi in
the film and both of them have these
weird little beady eyes basically just
pupils without the white sclera around
it but Baby Peach her eyes are fully
formed they're big and they're blue and
they have a giant sclera probably has
more to do with being consistent with
the already existing designs of the baby
versions of these characters that we see
in the video games but it does certainly
add more evidence to the peach isn't
human pile the babies that we know are
humans have eyes that look this way and
the babies that might not be human but
might come from outer space look like
this another big Point here when Peach
first meets Mario she excitedly asks him
you're a human you are a human right
before commenting that she thought he'd
be bigger and asking where he came from
but obviously that then begs the
question how does peach know what a
human is for someone who grew up with a
race of fungus people since she was a
literal infant it's a weird piece of
knowledge to have the bigger issue here
though is that kids lose their memories
at a certain point in childhood usually
around the age of three when they become
verbal they undergo what's known as
childhood Amnesia the natural and
gradual loss of memories from the first
few years of life in this scene we see
Peach using a pacifier but also able to
walk now human babies begin walking
anywhere between 10 and 18 months and
pacifiers can honestly hang around as
long as parents are willing to let their
kids use them the long and short of this
is that peach in the scene is probably
around the age of Two And even if Peach
human and knew about it at this age that
knowledge would likely have been lost as
part of the childhood Amnesia process
instead the knowledge of what a human is
seems more like some sort of innate
knowledge that an Intergalactic traveler
might have or at least someone who's
gotten a lot of knowledge about the
different galaxies and the races that
are contained therein there's also a ton
of evidence that we can actually bring
in here from the games as well in some
truly ancient game theories that are
almost nine years old at this point we
talked about the origins and parentage
of the character Rosalina a space
traveling princess from the Mario Galaxy
Games who is quite literally mother to
the Stars those theories are great by
the way they hold up really well they're
old but man to this day they are some of
my favorites that we've ever done anyway
to quickly summarize here throughout
Super Mario Galaxy Rosalina reads from a
storybook about a sad little girl in
search of illuma's missing mother though
it's never explicitly stated the story
is likely about Rosalina herself in the
book we see glimpses of Rosalina's
mother who looks an awful lot like Peach
and who also has herself peaches
earrings we also see Rosalina's
childhood castle one that has itself the
exact same silhouette as Peach's castle
in most depictions symmetrical spiers on
the sides and one large Spire in the
middle genetically Rosalina's eye color
hair color earlobes and even her
left-handedness would all match with
Peach and even the author of this
storybook portion of the game has gone
on record to say that his original
intent was for Rosalina and Peach to be
related there's also the French
translation of this story which makes
mention of a father's signature mustache
so isn't it suspicious then that the
movie goes out of its way to further the
connection between Peach and other
galaxies the filmmakers are outright
doing everything their power but
spelling out peaches Rosalina's mom in
the night sky additionally the captive
nihilistic lumali from the movie
outright says time like hope is an
illusion another Point towards that old
theory of iterative variants of the
universe and the connection between
Peach and the stars I suspect that in
Movie 3 they'll be coming to this
realization of the family connection and
then there will be a final reset of the
timeline to start things all over again
exactly what we saw with the original
Mario Galaxy and finally that brings us
to Theory number four or I guess more
observation number four as we talked
about earlier we see Mario playing Kida
Icarus on the Nintendo Entertainment
System the very first Home console that
Nintendo released stateside now at first
you might be thinking to yourself so
what famous Nintendo product being
featured as an Easter egg in a movie
about Nintendo's biggest franchise
what's the big deal with that well it's
actually huge you see if Mario's a real
person in this universe that means that
his games don't exist now some version
of Donkey Kong or in this case Jump Man
still exists in this universe we see an
altered version of the original Donkey
Kong arcade cabinet in the punch out
Pizzeria with a yeti in place of DK and
different humans in the places of Mario
and lady but everything that Mario as an
IP has touched doesn't really seem to be
a thing in this world the existence of
the punch out Pizzeria means that Mike
Tyson's punch out couldn't have been a
game in fact Mario's complete lack of
acknowledgment towards any of the
Mushroom Kingdom Donkey Kong Koopa Army
the Yoshi imagery all of that means that
basically nothing related to Mario
brothers or Yoshi's Island or Donkey
Kong Country exist as video games in
this world now on the surface that might
not seem like much until you remember
that without the Mario games there would
be no Nintendo see when the NES hit
store shelves the United States was in
the midst of the video game Crash of
1983. consumers didn't trust video games
because there had been such a huge
surplus of poorly made garbage games
like the infamous Atari version of ET
years before that sentiment was only
able to get turned around when Nintendo
released the Nintendo Entertainment
System marketing the thing as more of a
toy than a video game which proved games
really could be good actually and the
main way they proved that the original
Super Mario Brothers platformer was a
pack in title for the console Americans
only started to trust video games again
when they popped in Super Mario Brothers
and saw that it was a high quality fun
game and the numbers absolutely reflect
this fact the Nintendo Entertainment
System had a launch lineup of 17 games
including the likes of kung fu Hogan's
alley gyromite excitebike a lot of ones
that you know really please set the
world on fire clearly and then of course
he had the creatively titled games like
golf pinball baseball and of course
there was also Mario and of that group
Mario stood Head and Shoulders Above the
Rest of the nes's top five selling games
three of them are Mario games Super
Mario Brothers alone as a pack and title
for the console sold 40 million units it
is one of the top selling video games of
all time those Mario games at the top of
the list total around 65 million units
sold the only game in the top five to
not be a pack-in or Mario game sold 8
million Zelda Nintendo's second highest
performing IP only sold six and a half
million and don't even get me started on
Kid Icarus who couldn't even crack the
top 30 with only 1.7 million units sold
what I'm trying to say here is that
without the Mario games the NES likely
wouldn't have caught the Public's
attention and Nintendo likely wouldn't
have survived the changing era of
entertainment heck video gaming itself
may not have existed as a medium
considering that Mario was the game that
won back everyone's trust at the very
least the industry would have likely
been set back by at least a decade from
where it is today no Super Mario means
no new revolutionary 3D video game
controls with Mario 64. that then
translates to no new 3D platformer
Revolution leading to games like
Banjo-Kazooie Spyro the Dragon and
Ocarina of Time no Mario Kart no Super
Smash Brothers completely omitting to
the most impactful and highest selling
video game franchises of all time and
the lackluster growth of video games
would probably also translate to
differences in the Sony PlayStation and
Xbox and all of this is without even
touching all the ancillary businesses
like the CGI Tech all the amazing
lighters and shaders and game engines
that have been built off the backs of
gaming and all of that gaming off the
back of Mario with Mario being a real
guy in this world instead of a video
game character it means that one of the
other Nintendo IPS had to have been the
one that spearheaded the Revival of
video gaming as we know it and based on
the fact that Mario has f-zero posters
and Star Fox replicas but no Triforce
merch no Kirby plushie no Samus calendar
it means that one of them were made into
games in this universe either in short
what we're seeing in the Mario movie is
a timeline where Kid Icarus was the
killer app for Nintendo's Rebirth of
Gaming all its vertical platforming all
its eggplants all of this
oh no we've entered into The Darkest
Timeline but hey that's just a theory a
film Theory and cut
given the wild success of the Mario
movie and The Last of Us series I expect
we're going to be seeing a lot more of
these video game tie-ins in the future I
mean we're already apparently getting
Minecraft movie led by Jason Momoa and I
shudder to think about what we're gonna
have to talk about on this channel when
the FNAF movie finally comes out but
we'll be there so if you want to see
what theories we come up with when those
movies start releasing trailers smash
that subscribe button like you're
smashing Bowser in the face that way
you're gonna be the first to see when
all of those things go live and as
always my friends I will see you next
week